[Music]  tonight on our walking dead show I  thought we'd attempt something that's  never been done on television before  okay now The Walking Dead has  established that people love watching  zombies we do I don't know why but we do  you know what else  television viewers love to watch lesbian  kisses think about it a lesbian kiss is  an erotic and electrifying way to smash  forbidden cultural taboos well tonight  for the first time ever we are combining  these two television iconic moments  right now please enjoy the first lesbian  zombie kiss  [Music]  they love each other very much give me a  little romantic music please help them  out here let's help set the scene oh  that's nice and take it away  lesbian zombies awkward not sure how  this is going to go think the gun is  almost skidding  [Applause]  [Applause]  I don't think that's really so much a  kissing sort of a lesbian all alright  ladies and gentlemen --this they seem to  be fine just let them go out it